je vais poser des questions à nos
chroniqueurs je compte sur vous pour
donner les réponses alors comment faire
pour avoir des tomates qui ont du goût
il faut retirer la peau il ne faut pas
les mettre au réfrigérateur
il faut les mettre sous l'eau froide où
il faut les remplacer par des kebabs ne
sont pas les mettre au réfrigérateur
regarder la réponse sur les taux comme
les tomates
pour les français c'est surtout la
tomate qui a perdu son goût d'antan mais
pour quelles raisons pour consommer des
tomates qui ont du goût surtout acheté
la bonne saison et puis acheter les à
maturité mais surtout ne les mettez pas
au réfrigérateur vous avez complètement
abîmé le goût de la tomate que j'ai à
coeur et pas dans le site non plus
m'accuse t on qu'on sait c'est bon pour
la tomate tu nous fais bien pour la
tomate
ouais ça stoppe l'activité du fruit la
tomate est un fruit qui est vivant je
suis produit des arômes en permanence
quand vous le mettez à 4 degrés cette
production s'arrête et la tomate père
césar ou et c'est quoi une tomate avec
une cape super thoma bravo merci pour le
reste les biscuits deviennent durs non
merde pourquoi les biscuits dur devienne
mou et les gâteaux nous deviennent durs
car l'humidité du gâteau s'équilibre
avec celle de l'eire pour que kelly est
une excuse afin de manger tout le fath
et d'un quart la farine cuite se
transforme au bout de 48 heures ou bien
c'est la conséquence de la création de
bactéries la réponse q l'humidité du
gâteau car des témoins l'a34 la croix
vous dites quoi vous la farine cuite ou
non
que non alors en fait la une et la deux
ah merde vous mais c'est fou c'est fou
ça ça vous n'avez pas regardé la réponse
la réponse
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est ça leur mac 1 donc le g coire
fait l'humidité c'est kim la nature tout
ans équilibré quand vous sortez un bus
qui très sec
il ya peu d'eau à l'intérieur l'humilité
l'air va rentrer dans le biscuit pour
que ça s'équilibre donc jusqu'où va
devenir mou celle inverse pour un
biscuit qui est très sec qui croque ans
qui a peu douche
évidemment vous avez d'humilité qui va
qui va arriver voilà donc les induire
spa dont les très mou vont durcir et les
très dures ont ramolli
lorsque kelly a raison dans les 48
heures une fois que vous avez ouvert le
sachet
je suis d'accord c'est pas qu'il y ait
une impression ballon mais je vois une
réponse facile et très fan de vous ils
vous regardent tous les dimanches c'est
vrai hockey mineur
oui c'est vrai mais bamako je n'ai pas
reçu un message de quoi je ne crois pas
mais c'était ma vie c'était le plus beau
jour de ma vie c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
merci parce que c'est passé j'ai reçu
des messages bonjour c'est mac lesggy g1
je sais que vous mmes adoré j'ai un
projet vous présenter mais j'étais trop
contente assez vite j'ai dit c'est
bizarre je reçois un message de mon
idole et il me dit je sais pas de quoi
tu me parles vas-y vierge art tout seul
chez pas quoi boxée par cyril vous
faites jour le show de plaisance mais
c'est ça la cruauté de cette blague
c'est que j'aime et je trouve ça un peu
cruel voulait faire un petit bisou à mac
mais j'adorerais malaisie
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
question technique puisqu'on est dans le
il ya même si cela oui mais en ce moment
est ce qu'on fait pour que l'on reçoit
un message de vous sans que votre numéro
apparaît bien entendu mais qu'est ce
qu'il m'arrive bien mais c'était pour la
faire qu'il fait après midi au coeur
alors quand on mange double soir on dort
mal car oui ça augmente le taux de
testostérone notre intestin fait une
castaldi tu ça ralentit la sécrétion de
l'hormone du sommeil ou ça augmente la
température corporelle manger lourd
lorsqu'on mange sa demande à l'eau à
l'intestin de travailler et ça que ça
fait dépenser d'ailleurs des kilos quand
vous mangez
parce que ça fait faire de l'effort dont
je pense que ça augmente la température
oui car elle a parfaitement raison
effectivement et c'est pour ça notamment
petit actuelle et les petits génies
parce que le la nuit le corps la
température du corps version pc est
petit truc que je vous donne le matin
que vous rêviez
prenez une douche chaude quel que soit
le nombre d'heures que vous ai dormi la
température monte derrière vous êtes
nickel à chaque serait jamais reçue est
un peu mince le soir les doulas une
excellente réponse effectivement c'était
un moindre effet ça moi et mathieu la
complète avec quelque chose tenir c'est
juste le matin on se réveille toujours
avec une douce chaudron l'on n'a pas
alors ce qui m'amène c'est une mauvaise
nuit volontairement hier soir j'ai dîné
à 10 heures du soir d'une entrecôte
sauce béarnaise av
des frites et quelques verres de vin en
conséquence j'ai eu énormément de mal à
m'endormir
pourquoi on dit toujours qu'il faut
diminuer sa température corporelle pour
avoir un bon sommeil c'est une action de
digestion qui va augmenter la
température corporelle donc là on va
complètement à l'encontre de ce qu'il
faut pour s'endormir et avoir un bon
sommeil qui dormait en taule adaptive
walad hors de moi parlions majors voient
la chercher dans sa boîte en métal doré
bien quoi tu deviens toi ouais tu as tu
des cinq heures tu dois maintenant les
bébés 4,5 à regarder doc gynéco il dort
à 9 heures dans l'émission
novergie 8 vous irez pourquoi les
personnes âgées donc là pardon et
dorment si peu c'est très vrai c'est
pourquoi quand on voit les skis pourquoi
les personnes âgées dans ma vie du père
castor
non mais vous le savez ou pas n'ayant
pas encore trouvé le sujet je n'en sais
rien c'est vrai mais tu fais pas mal ça
tu devais faire ma même sujet mais oui
mais makeba vas-y alors moi j'ai
toujours dormi peu à je vous le dis tout
y passe que vous m'avez regarderai kgb
de 58 ans non mais quoi j'ai toujours
dormi deux heures deux heures et demie
je suis pareil ça c'est le traumatisme
des bombardements pendant la guerre
[Applaudissements]
et là et là on va parler de ce qui est
ma passion et de passion dans la vie mac
l'amour et le cheveu laquelle de ces
informations sur les cheveux est vrai le
cuir chevelu est l'endroit le plus sale
du corps humain lorsqu'on coupe un
cheveu et souffre car il est vivant non
on produit un kilomètre de cheveux par
mois les cheveux de jean michel mr
cyniquement les soirs de pleine lune
dans une clinique en clair alors locale
entre le maître lattois laluquoise elle
est une réponse du match environ cent
mille cheveux sur la tête qui pousse
tous les mois d'un centimètre boutabout
nous produisons donc l'équivalent d'un
kilomètre de cheveux par mois et par
personne
et quand on les coupe c'est comme les
ongles ça ne fait pas mal
ouais c'est bien ce sujet là j'aime bien
la surface inscriptions et chouchou bien
en être un ok avec le temps c'est ma
passion pas passion oui on a quand même
des champions ce casta et de lanvaux
crois que c'était chaque cheveu plus
d'un kilomètre à chaque fois de voir ce
qu'ils disaient bah oui mais on pensait
que c'était une boutade oui on va
arriver arriva ouais nan mais bon tu
t'inquiètes pas tu y en a bien une
sautée je veux une boutade rab
merci